okay so sleep
is snoring natural or not
no
no
no it's not it's not natural at all
and it neither is sleep apnea it just so
happens to be that so many people do it
we think it's normal just like having
crooked teeth is not natural okay
we weren't intended to have crooked
teeth how many people have crooked about
90
right
so
there are some breeds of dogs that have
been bred to have very flat faces guess
what they have the same breathing
problems that that we have but any other
animal in the wild the vast majority of
animals they're not going to snore and
they're not going to have sleep apnea
and
according to the skeletal record our
ancestors very likely suffered from very
little snoring and sleep apnea as well
what causes snoring
snoring is caused by this soft tissue in
the back of the throat
vibrating right so it it can happen as
at the back of the nasopharynx as well
which is why some people breathe through
their nose they're like hey i'm still
snoring
because it can happen back there so
that's from this flabby tissue sleep
apnea is different that's a blockage
usually your tongue
it can happen that way it can also
happen in in other areas the oropharynx
hypopharynx but
one of the leading reasons why so many
of us suffer from snoring and sleep
apnea beyond weight which plays a huge
role in this
but one of the leading reasons why
people who are average weight or
underweight can suffer from these things
is our mouths
have shrunk over the last few hundred
years the human mouth has gotten
so small that our teeth no longer fit
and that's the main reason why we're
suffering from so many of these chronic
respiratory issues weight lifters know
all about sleep apnea and snoring
because when you get too many muscles
around your neck but your throat is not
developed properly to handle that inflow
and exhaling of air you can suffer from
sleep apnea which is one of the reasons
why so many weight lifters can suffer
from hypertension is because they they
suffer from sleep problems
it's fascinating to think that snoring
isn't something that's natural it's like
a
it's like a rite of passage almost you
know it's such a cultural artifact that
everybody you have someone in a cartoon
and they're asleep the way that they
show that they're asleep is the fact
that they're snoring
yeah i mean this is this is how bad
things have gotten you know it's and
once i started getting deeply into this
field so a lot of us know by now sleep
apnea is such bad news like have you
ever had it i i don't think i've got it
i think i'd know if i did
i only had it when i was in the stanford
experiment and i plugged my nose i
instantly got sleep apnea which is
really scary
it feels well you're unconscious right
so you don't feel it happening it's just
you wake up and you you feel like you
haven't slept a wink
uh your body's all messed you're
starving
you're
you have anxiety you can't think
straight it's really bad and 20 of the
population can tell you how bad it is
because that's that's roughly the amount
who suffers from it but what people
don't get is that snoring
and now the science is really coming out
about this can have so many of the same
problems as sleep apnea what happens
when you're inhibiting airflow in and
out of your body you're stressing
yourself out all night
you have to struggle to breathe for
eight hours out of the night you're not
getting that proper deep sleep we know
that and and all of that rest and
restoration that is supposed to happen
in sleep takes a huge hit and i was just
talking to matthew walker about this and
he's like i totally agree no one's
talking about snoring they think it's
cute when you see an infant snoring this
is someone who's struggling to get
energy right and it's going to
completely wreck them later on in life
all right so what are the top tips for
improving breathing during sleep
breathe through your nose easier said
than done right some people need surgery
okay some people can benefit from having
these mouth guards those work as well
but becoming a nasal breather
only has benefit there are no side
effects is it going to cure all your
problems is it going to cure every
single person snoring to sleep apnea
no is it going to help you across the
board at some level yes so why not do it
i use a little piece of sleep tape i
found that's beneficial other people
have used other props whatever works
putting the head of your bed up about
six inches has been proved proven to be
helpful for some people
uh because it helps
gravity when you're putting your head
down flat you're working against gravity
your tongue is more apt to fall back in
in the back of your mouth so putting a
couple pillows up and i'm a huge fan of
this and it's free and again there's no
negative side effects i just got some
books
and put the head of the bed up by six
inches it's called so they went under
the mattress
no no no uh under under the bed stand
you don't want to feel books when you're
when you're sleeping okay all right so
yeah the entire bed is now at a little
bit
incline bed therapy check check it out
so the whole bed is at a slant now they
sell
sleep number thing you can spend 10
grand it's being commercialized they
just need some books
you need some books or some bricks or
some wood or whatever the hell you have
sitting around
so i found that's helpful for people who
want to try to
figure out their snoring
using their natural body sleeping on
your back can really exacerbate snoring
and sleep apnea you can tape a little
ping pong ball or a sock to the back of
a t-shirt so that you don't sleep on
your back they used to do this with
people in the military because you get
much better sleep when you're not
snoring so i can tell your your
listeners may be into doing this and you
can record
what's working for you with an app i
like an app called snorelab no they
aren't paying me to say that they have a
free version of it otherwise it's like
two bucks but this records your sleep
throughout the night and you can wear
whatever sleep tracker you want and look
at the quality of your sleep and i've
found that these things can make an
incredible difference
for some snoring and some sleep apnea
and again
they're basically free and uh
there's only benefits associated with
them do you know how many people are
going to go to bed with a ping pong ball
strapped to their back their mrs or
their partner or whatever's going to say
is that a what have you got that don't
worry about this thing modern wisdom was
on earlier on don't worry about it
do you know how many people go to bed
strapping a terrestrial scuba mask to
their face no so they don't suffer from
sleep a cpap machine is that what it is
how they manifest it onto their face
do you know how many tens of millions of
people
are sleeping with a mask that pumps air
in and out of their bodies every night
because if they didn't have this
their sleep would be a complete disaster
and they die of hypertension so
a ping pong ball may seem here we go
with that what's really weird who's the
weirdo ping pong ball may seem like a
very stupid trick right
it's no stupider than living with sleep
apnea or snoring which is causing a lot
of health problems so
and it's free wear a sock if a sock get
a cute sock and put that on your back if
that's if that's going to help you
um but these these things you don't have
to do these things you can wear a cpap
and cpaps work but here are a few tricks
you can try that won't cost you anything
i hadn't ever heard of the
vertical bed
incline
thing before that's a really really good
idea
this is right up your alley and and now
there's there's some real science coming
out check out incline bed therapy and
there's some guy who's been studying it
for 20 years he's he's pretty wacky but
he sleeps vertically now he's he's
managed to work his tolerance to the
point where he's at 90 degrees he's
gotten so good yeah now he sells straps
and duct tape and you can just tape
yourself up every night and there you go
glad you brought that up another new
market everybody check amazon soon
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace
you